foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
we're glad you're here open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five good to be back in the studio Jade
and I and a bunch of the Ramsey
personalities have been on the road we
were in Salt Lake City last week
returned yesterday from Anaheim from
doing an event out in in CA in
California
both both of you crowds were absolutely
incredible thank you guys you were very
welcoming it was so good to be in both
locations and be out in America seeing
you guys and we will never again after
quarantines and stuff take for granted
the ability to gather as a group and
cheer on really good ideas and so we're
really excited to be with you guys and
the good news is we will be back on the
microphone for a while yes we're not
traveling for a while and so we'll be
here saddled into this thing and
answering you guys questions so thanks
for hanging out with us and for all of
the uh the other Ramsey personalities
covering the bases while we've been
hitting the road the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Lisa's in Charlotte
North Carolina hi Lisa how are you
such an honor to talk to you Dave hello
how are you an honor to speak with you
as well how can we help I am doing
wonderful first of all thank you for
telling us the truth you've got giving
us a path and in this hope that our
future can be bright not there are not
too many people that that are doing that
today so thank you for what you guys do
so here's my question
um I'm 60 years old and I have two
retirement related questions I'm
retiring for my full-time teaching job
at the end of this year from which I
will have a monthly pension paid to me
for the rest of my life I have a
one-time opportunity to take a partial
month-star maximum withdrawal which I
estimate will be around 148
000 that'll reduce my monthly benefit by
about a thousand dollars a month my only
vet is my house
um right now it's 230k I'm estimating it
to be about 215k by the time I retire at
the end of this year I think Dave you
would tell me to take the one time
withdrawal and apply it to my mortgage
which would reduce my mortgage to about
105 000 when I retire
my reduced monthly benefit would cover
my monthly expenses plus I also
currently have two part-time jobs that I
will probably keep for a while so my
first question is is it the right
decision to take the lump sum withdrawal
yes
you're right that's what I thought
here's the thing you're not going to get
a cash flow benefit from this till you
finish paying off the mortgage though
that is correct so you've got to knock
because you're reducing your income by a
thousand bucks a month but you're not
increasing your income by reducing your
mortgage now you're not decreasing your
mortgage payment by reducing your
mortgage balance until you pay it off so
we got to have a plan for knocking that
other 105 out as fast as you can
well my plan was was to keep the two
part-time jobs that I have now because
my monthly pension will cover all of my
expenses so those other two part-time
jobs but you're quitting teaching but I
can still stay aggressive I am quitting
full-time teaching yes but I also teach
part-time okay why are you quitting it's
60.
my first retirement
day so why are you retiring at six times
um
for me to move on for on Fire Red so you
just won a second act
okay well listen listen step in step in
and start doing some professorship
online and some other things and make
some serious bank and make as much as
you were making teaching for the next
two years and pay that mortgage off
I don't like part-time jobs when I still
got a mortgage I want you and you're
only 60. you're just a pup
I can't can I ask can I ask a question
in this so is there any is there any
point if she continues to work full-time
even though if it's not teaching
couldn't she take that lump sum and
invest it in better Investments she
could but we're but we're on baby step
six and any extra money we get it's not
going into Investments while there's
still a mortgage that's always going to
go on the mortgage so that's where she
that's why that's why she went there I
see it correctly went there and but the
but the problem is it doesn't gave it
doesn't in the short term give you any
net benefit until we knock that mortgage
out so what I want to do somehow is gear
up your income and your focused
intensity not crazy intensity but let's
get that 105 done because then you're
going to not have a mortgage because of
this move and that's going to increase
your net situation by more than a
thousand dollars agreed
absolutely agree yes yeah so that that's
where we want to go is that's what we
got to get to for this to have a net
effect overall because the 148th phone
at the mortgage without paying it off
does not change the mortgage payment
that's right and uh so that's that's we
got to get to that other part of it and
um
it sounds like you're just you're just
done with whatever you're doing
emotionally that's cool I got no issue
with that but there's people making bank
as online professors and you control
your own time that is true really good
money I mean you can maybe more than
you're making now I don't know what
you're making but maybe more than you're
making now
ands in Las Vegas hey Ann welcome to the
Ramsay show
yeah hi thanks for having me so
basically my husband and I purchased the
house it's 33 of our total income and we
have about 84 000 in debt now we got
into a Dave Ramsey Show at this point
because obviously that was pretty stupid
and now I'm nervous because I'm
wondering if we should try to get rid of
the house but he says we shouldn't
how if you can turn the corner without
getting rid of the house and probably
keep the house go ahead that's what I'm
going to say I'm going to say how How
likely is it that you can increase your
income by eight percent and clear that
close that Gap
well right now I am in the process of
getting a job so hopefully that falls
goes through I'll find out today and
that will that will help out a lot
you're not working and you're going to
add how much income
well I'm retired military so right now I
make 34 but with the job I'm trying to
get I'll make almost 80. oh more
so you're going to increase your
household income eighty thousand dollars
40 40 about 40 000 oh you so you got 40
in retirement from military
yeah okay so you're going to increase
your household income the 33 Problem by
40 Grand right
keep the house
okay okay but here's the deal you're
looking in the rearview mirror you got
84 000 worth of stupid and you've got a
decision on buying a house you couldn't
afford so this has got to stop
we have to turn around and go the other
direction right
yeah like the worm has turned you guys
are going to get freaking serious now
you have sell so much stuff the kids
think they're next
yeah definitely yeah definitely and no
going out to eat and you have 84 000
worth of debt oh and you don't need to
go on vacation broke people don't go on
vacation
so let's get the 84 cleaned up is this
okay am I okay with you
yeah that's perfect we're doing we're
using every dollar now we're going
through
um FPU so yeah we're we're trying to get
it together okay you got you got your
act going okay because I can I can sense
a turnaround but I wanted to enhance it
as I don't want just to increase your
income for to keep the house and then
sit on our right right you know sit on
this it's not not going to work so yeah
that won't go this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Chris Is With Us in
Atlanta hi Chris welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call so
just a little bit of background I'm 42.
I am a tree hospital and
um I have been haven't been debt free
all my life probably last 15 years but
um I feel guilty every time I spend
money we have 401k savings we invest
money I still work my wife still works
but it changed me to spend anything over
a hundred dollars sometimes
um so I was wondering if you could tell
me do you still feel that even after 30
years of being debt free or whatnot
because I feel it our house is paid off
we have no payments and I still get that
clinching in my stomach every time we
have to go do anything I can't relax and
have fun I was wondering if you could
tell me maybe how you feel or if you
felt the same way after you got out of
debt and those built a bunch of wealth
it's not it's not guilt it's fear
that makes sense
and what that is is Dr John deloney
would say your body is remembering
being broke
and it's telling you that that your
spending is a threat it's a threat it's
a threat it's a threat and so your fear
activates
that's what happened to me anyway
even 10 years after you got debt debt
free not 10 years but for a while it did
and I I what I did is just what you've
done I just recognized it was happening
and I kind of like you're doing I
started asking the question what the
Flip's going on I mean what's wrong with
you you got a million dollars
yeah pissing and moaning about going to
the grocery store for you know I
apologize my life crazy yeah I mean
that's what that's what that was me
talking to me not you okay but I'm just
saying I had to kind of go okay and
again I'll just bring I'll Channel my
inner deloney God help us but um yeah
but the you're doing good uh but but the
you know the the thing it
um
I had to do two things one is I had to
say all right facts are my friends
okay so what is your net worth Chris
I would say probably 2.2 and you're 42
years old and you're 100 debt free and
your household income is what
uh around
275. okay so let's just be realistic for
a second if we took 200
000 dollars
and hundred dollar bills
out of your net worth
and put it in the fireplace and burned
it
he's now got a cold sweats Jade I know
he does if we did that yeah if we did
that your life is not going to change
one percent
really that's a fact no that's a fact
other than this breakdown that you would
have but I'm just saying but the but you
know what I'm saying mathematically are
you as okay with 2 million as you are
with 2.2 you are we know that to be true
that is a fact
it's a fact
so when you go
and and and and go on a nice vacation
and drop 10 grand for your poor wife
who's put up with you
trust me I just did that and I had a
nervous break I know I know but the
reason is you're you're acting like your
your fear mechanism is activating as if
you're broke and the facts tell us that
that is a false signal
and can I take it one further Chris
because I kind of relate to some of what
you're saying um on Sam and I's journey
through this debt-free journey and then
some I've had to go there's been certain
moments that I've had to go back and
find where that emotion is coming from
and I've had to think back on what what
was the instance where that was ignited
like okay it was when I asked for lunch
money and and someone blew up on me
right or it was because I did this and
that was the first time that it was a
phrase you heard yes we ain't got no
money
that was a phrase I heard growing up
Chris and there's been so many times in
my life I've had to go back and find
where that came from and speak to it
directly and go hey if if I if I buy
this pair of tennis shoes right now it's
not going to break the budget No One's
Gonna yell at me No One's Gonna you know
what I've had to go back and say that if
I buy what I would like to have for
lunch at the grocery store there's no
guilt there I'm not going to throw the
budget off the family's not going to pay
for I've had to say that and I think
sometimes my guess is that there's some
things that have happened that have
caused some trigger in you and you've
got to go back and identify that and
honestly speak directly to it and say
hey I'm not there anymore
another one another place we've dealt
with this Chris was um once I kind of
started getting past it the fear the
sheer it's not fear is sheer Terror that
my wife Sharon felt when we went
bankrupt and lost everything and we had
a brand new baby and a toddler and the
lights got cut off
if I even have a similar body language
or tone 30 years later
towards spending like the emergency fund
and it makes it activates that it
triggers that inside of her we have to
we have to just time out and back up
because she has to start breathing again
it because she I can I can she's she
feels like I'm doing what I did when I
went broke for just a nanosecond and it
activates and all of these lights light
up in her in her uh her physical body
changes I mean her her she gets pissed
off from being really terrified again
and it just doesn't yeah yeah and it it
activates all fear and anger are best
friends they run around together and so
um terrible feeling yeah it is it is but
here's the point okay number one facts
are your friends
yeah all you gotta do is when you start
doing that you just have to stop and go
now wait a minute that's not real
this is this is fear that's called false
evidence appearing real this is a this
is a falsehood us spending this money is
not irresponsible and it's not going to
break our family and you just have to
talk to yourself and build the muscle
then of doing that the other thing you
can do is you give a very specific
process put in place and go okay like
for instance Sharon and I we do not
spend
or give more than a thousand dollars
without talking to each other and if
it's more than a thousand dollars we
wait overnight also
we breathe now do we have to do that
mathematically today absolutely not and
we got all kinds of margin but we do it
as an act of respect to each other to
keep from activating those scars those
wounds from having gone broke and uh you
know it was the first five years after
going broke for me and even today I'm
telling you that we still if we're if we
don't abide by some certain processes
that are safety valves then we can still
step back over that line and their
emotional processes they're not
mathematical processes because again we
could give away I mean we could take X
number of dollars and put it in the
middle floor and burn it and it wouldn't
affect our lives we've got the money
it's not that's not the issue so
mathematically it's not the problem but
but the action the body language the
tone the process used seems impulsive
irresponsible out of control immature
and it feels like the old days that's
right and Boyle light your butt up it
will I mean it's just another component
to when we say money is I mean it's
behavioral and it's behavioral in the
moment but it's also taking into account
the behaviors you did beforehand and you
feel that and you're still connected to
those and so when you get in a moment
where you're like why am I freaking out
right now you know when I know for Sam
if the bank account used to hit a
certain number he'd start being like
okay okay we gotta go do something okay
and and that's the way it is we can't
act like these things didn't have an
effect on us mentally and that that
behavior didn't affect us because it
does not I am much more healed yes 30
years ago
than I was 30 months after the
bankruptcy yes you know 30 years later
versus 30 months later and so you should
go through a healing process but it's
also just wise to acknowledge what's
really going on here and then number one
we're gonna say oh that's not real
number two you look at the actual ratios
and go okay we're not being
irresponsible so why am I feeling you
know and then you learn to you practice
your way through normal feelings versus
wounded feelings this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
yeah
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
guys there's some weird stuff going on
out there in the Work World in the labor
market and it is crushing
particularly small business owners they
have had to deal with the great
resignation quiet quitting and a lack of
people signing up that are skilled
workers for jobs
and they can't get their work done
because they can't get the help they
need it's been Relentless these
participation trophies and helicopter
parents are making snowflakes at a
record rate
and um and it's a problem
it's a real problem now I got to tell
you gen Z and Millennials we love those
Generations we got a bunch of them here
they're absolutely incredible and
there's some of them that are useless
now the ones that are useless aren't
here we don't let them work here but the
uh the ones that are awesome are
absolutely amazing we got a bunch of
them on this team so to put this chaos
in perspective
uh political Economist Nicholas
eberstadt found that seven million
able-bodied males have just left the
workforce
they're just not looking for work
they're not in the unemployment
statistics they're living in their
mother's basement their girlfriend's
house or their wife is working and they
are just not choosing to work this is
insane it's not good for them it's not
good for the economy business owners
need to know how to make it to the other
side of this mess so tonight Thursday
May the 4th yes I know it's Star Wars
day I'm teaming up with micro and five
best-selling authors and experts for our
America's labor crisis live stream we'll
be doing the live stream from the Ramsey
Event Center here this evening micro has
uh came back with us from La when we
were out there yesterday and I've had
the blessing of spending a lot of time
with Mike lately and I really think the
world of this guy we're going to talk
about work ethic
and we're going to talk about how to
hire in these situations and we're going
to talk about how to lead properly
so that you attract the right kind of
people and we're going to bring in all
these Experts of what's really going on
because there's some very interesting
Dynamics in the marketplace right now so
if you are in business or want to be in
business and you want to learn about
this labor crisis that's going on it's a
free live stream tonight
ramseysolutions.com labor crisis it'll
be right on the front page of the
website at rimsysolutions.com and boom
you can sign up watch it starts at 7 pm
central time and we would absolutely
love to have you so Jade the Department
of Education has issued guidance to
student loan companies to begin
collecting payments in September so you
mean these people really want their
money back and you mean the president's
actually going to let them do it
he's announced that he's running for
reelection I know now he's going to make
you pay your student loans is he though
do you think he's going to try to kick
it down the can kick the can down the
road one more time no you think this is
it I think I don't think the Department
of Education would have put this notice
out if they weren't going to do it
because they've not done this in the
future that's true that is a very good
point all of the other deadlines that
were approaching they were silent that's
true he kicked the can he kicked the
candy kicked the can and this time I
think he's going to do it now I have to
have another I have to have an alternate
Theory and that would be okay so when we
get up closer to election
uh it's going to come up that he didn't
really forgive the student loans of
course unless he does something again
so expect another announcement
during the election year but also expect
to start paying your payments again in
September that's true and I can't help
but think about the effect of this on
folks because I think the average
student loan payment is about 480 and
people have gotten I mean it's been
three years people have gotten so used
to three years three years that's
unbelievable
that's crazy and people have I mean it's
this is your lifestyle now people bought
houses
based off of that they don't have their
student loan payments yes and they
bought cars Dave based on
they bought look they traded in that 480
student loan payment for Carno for 480
yeah but don't waste a good crisis
because we had a we had a quarantine
that was in in our area was about 30
days yeah and
um
but we got three good years out of it
three years
so I wonder crisis I just wondered Dave
when when those payments hit August 31st
is supposed to be that that magic date
and I just wonder how this is going to
affect people's Financial world I mean
think about it people overspent like
crazy here's the other thing from a
political standpoint you gotta think
about this you can't wait until just
before the election to do this if he
does it now they're going to be pissed
off at him that's what I'm saying well
forget about it by November next
yeah that's true so if people have the
attention span of a gnat they don't
remember they can't stay pissed off for
a whole year yeah and so 14 months
that's true so that that it's really I
mean you have to know that these are
Political Animals and these Political
Animals function a hundred percent of
the time on Instinct and the instinct is
politics it is not reality they may or
may not forget they may forget it
depends on the outcome don't forget it
because if this if this causes folks to
have to change their lifestyle well they
might still be bitter
don't forget don't forget
because they can't they I'm telling you
these
you're right though I mean you're right
people do forget quickly yeah I mean so
the White House announced last November
the federal student loan payments would
resume 60 days after the education
department is allowed to initiate its
student loan forgiveness plan or after
the Supreme Court litigation is resolved
whichever comes first in February the
Supreme Court heard arguments
against President Biden student loan
forgiveness plan and they're expected to
issue a rolling
in late June or early July and so
basically they've given him a tip of the
hat and said uh we are not going to rule
in your favor that's what it is and so
July plus 60
there it is yeah July plus 60. wow it's
an omen what's activating it is the
Supreme Court thing yeah so he's going
to lose yeah he knows it and they're
being kind by giving him this
forewarning yes
well they weren't supposed to do that
but they do that and now this is your
warning to get your budding Gear Well I
mean why did you get ready for that did
you think it was going to go away Dave
people thought they thought wrong I know
they didn't think
thinking is a lost art form Sebastian is
with us Sebastian's in West Palm Beach
hey Sebastian how are you
hey Dave hey Jade thank you so much for
having me you bet uh so my question is I
bought a house uh last year August
um I'm a software engineer at that time
we were working hybrid where we go to
the office
um twice a month so once every two weeks
and I was looking to buy a house and
everything in my area was just out of my
budget or everything that was in my
budget me and my wife didn't think it
was appropriate for us so we bought a
house about an hour and a half away from
my office
and I figured that drive is doable uh
once every two weeks fast forward almost
a year now and now my job is basically
saying we're still a hybrid but we're
gonna need to come into the office twice
a week and what I'm trying to figure out
is I mean I guess that drive is a little
doable but I've been wondering if it's a
good idea to maybe rent my house out and
buy something else closer to my office
why would you rent the house out why
would you not just sell it and purchase
a new house closer to where you're
living
yeah so I've thought about that me my
wife love the house like we and she
doesn't want to give it up for nothing
in the world but and I thought you
wouldn't be living in it
so our plan would be to rent it out I
know but you're putting renters in a
house you love this is not something you
do to things you love
okay she may love the house I mean that
I get that she loves the house but you
guys are trying to solve a problem and
sometimes when you're trying to solve a
problem you've got to make a sacrifice
and that's really what it boils down to
yeah what about changing jobs
so I mean I wouldn't
change yeah that's close to where you
live
I could probably um as a software
engineer there's kind of where I'm at
now it's not a big market for it you
have to go more closer to the bigger
stage or unless I go remote because I've
thought about that idea as well
um
it's just for the tech industry right
now it's a little bit tough
no it's not there's a shortage of
software Engineers I got three on the
books to hire right now
move to Tennessee work for us we need to
oh my gosh you know no I'm no I that's
not there's not a shortage there might
be a shortage of remotes remotes dying
quickly no pun intended but yeah the uh
I would sell my house and move closer to
work or I would change jobs I would not
keep it as a rental bad plan bad plan
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five if you're new to Ramsey and
a bunch of you are we know that based on
our ratings increases recently our
increased following on social media and
of course the podcast rankings are going
through the roof thank you guys if
you're brand new and you were trying to
figure out what it is we're speaking
around here because we do kind of use a
different lingo language vernacular then
uh just go to ramsesolutions.com click
on the get started button completely
free no salesman will call and we'll
help you figure out where you are and
start teaching you and giving you some
direction on things like baby steps and
death snowballs and all those kinds of
things
and so be sure and check all that out
Jennifer is with us in Detroit Michigan
hi Jennifer how are you
hello thanks for having me on sure
what's up
well I'm looking for your opinion I'm uh
new at this I'm a baby steps I guess you
would say uh I am 60 years old uh
divorced by co-care for my mother who
has dementia
um but I do have I have uh 600k in a
professionally managed retirement
account I own my own home outright
um I own two rental homes outright and I
own a development lot in the golf course
community that I'm going to sell to a
developer what I'm wondering is how I
grow my wealth um do I go do I put my
money from this land that I'm going to
sell into a professionally managed
account or do I put it back into real
estate
wow
you've done such a good job
well um
I think you're probably a whole lot
better than you think you are right
everything you told me was wisdom
okay well that's good to hear I just
need to make it last for my life so yeah
you're fine you're going to be okay
you're going to be just fine what's your
home worth
it's about a
million and what are the other pieces of
real estate worth
they have let's see I have two rental
properties that are probably a million
two total uh the lot that I own is a
million plus
yeah
four million dollar net worth
yeah you're 60 years old
yeah I think you need to be teaching the
classes not answering the question
asking questions
[Laughter]
well done well done so let me let me
tell you what you have done so far okay
so far you have kept your Investment
Portfolio very very clean
and in things that you felt comfortable
with and understood
real estate
and managed accounts
that's where all your wealth is
paid for Real Estate I might add okay
right
so why don't we just do that
yes your four million dollars net worth
is 60 years old nobody can argue with
your results
well that's good to hear I mean you
didn't do it in the last six months in
crypto and then lose it four months
later right no no you're not you're not
you don't live in stupidville I mean so
absolutely I I would be the one asking
you questions
Jennifer you've done such a great job
yeah I think you showed a lot because
you're going to there's no question
about that and you don't want
necessarily a million dollars tied up in
a single building a lot that's not
creating an income and you're going to
buy some income producing Properties or
you're going to put it into managed
accounts or you could do both you could
buy a half million dollar income
producing property and a half million
dollars into a managed account
okay that'd be okay all right so do you
like the real estate rentals
um it's okay I mean of course you know
you know we're a lot of work and finding
the right people and so forth and
so yeah it's okay I mean I I wouldn't
I mean I do it because I need to so yeah
well it's it's if you don't manage it
well it doesn't produce but when you go
through the extra hassle that you don't
have with the managed accounts you make
more money on the real estate than you
do on the management accounts but you
have more time invested agreed
right and I don't I only have a couple
so it's not that big of a deal yeah
a lot so
so maybe half and half then or I don't
care if you just if you had answered the
question said you know I love real
estate I think real estate's the place
to be it gets me excited I'm gonna go
buy a million dollar I'm gonna go buy a
little a little small strip center and
that's in a nice area that's going to be
easy to rent to some retailers and I'm
gonna make some money that way I have a
different kind of rental property and
because I love real estate that would be
an okay answer or I want to buy two more
houses or three more houses they'll be
no cancer or I hate dealing with renters
these two are about all I want and uh so
I'm going to dump it all into managed
funds all of these are good answers
okay it's what do you want to do but
here's what you did I want you to hear
it loud and clear you kept it simple
and you didn't put money in things
unless you understood them and you've
avoided fear and you've had a lot of
peace
well I've had a little fear well but I
mean by and large you haven't had a lot
to be afraid about
you don't have debt yeah you've got a
big pile of money you're 60 years old I
think you're highly successful I think
you did a unless you got divorced six
months ago and your husband ex-husband
did all this uh I'm very impressed
oh well thank you okay well that's good
to hear yeah I think you did a great job
and I would just I would do more of what
you have done and uh by the way this is
normative for the those of you out here
listening when we study millionaires
what do they do they're pretty boring
yeah yep
paid for home
retirement accounts money invested in
casual stage you know it's just it's
it's they're just they're not doing
double backflip family limited
Partnerships that somebody heard about
on midnight table
or Tic Tac
you know we're not we're not getting our
financial advice from the Chinese social
media channel oh my God you don't think
she rented out uh bought a quad Plex and
lives in the kitchen and she's not 57
million dollars in debt and thinks it
thinks it's sexy no she's not she's
brilliant very wise very cool very calm
but here's the thing when I have talked
to we used to do an event called uh
wealth
well something I can't think it was
called now but one when I was talking to
these wealthy people that came to this
thing they all felt like that they
should be doing something more
complicated and yet all of them are
sitting there with two five ten million
dollar net worth and the and the stuff
they're doing is working and it's very
the kiss principle keep it simple stupid
and man I learned from that I learned
from that I don't I don't do anything I
buy real estate I do the same thing she
does I got a real estate that's paid for
for as an investment uh I increased my
generosity Factor yeah and I and I
invest in mutual funds well that's
really all I do The infomercials make
you think there's a secret it's the
secret that's only society when you come
from an area that a group of people that
doesn't have money
then you you hear all the mythology
about rich people right all the theories
from poor people about rich people
that's right
and it's it's it's like unicorns and
Skittles and rainbows and stuff that
people like us don't understand and so
when people like us actually get there
then we think we did something wrong oh
wow yeah and it's just not true you did
exactly what you're supposed to do so
keep it simple stupid is a great rule
that's for me I use it for me and you
know put money only in things you
understand and that you have peace about
and uh and be playing long ball never
you know not don't we're not trying to
get rich quick we're thinking about 10
years out 20 years out 30 years out
which is why she's bailing on that lot
yeah she thinks that lot has peaked and
she's probably right I would have loved
to have interviewed her just a little
bit further to find out a little bit
more how she exactly how she did this
and the time frames and all of that well
she mentioned she was divorced so I
don't know when that occurred but at
some point she got a lump sum and a
broken heart that's right and in the
middle of those scars and tears had to
be wise that's right and fear had to be
wise and something led her in up this
path that is a really really good path
this is not a caller we can take credit
for their results because she had not
followed us yeah she's new to our stuff
so but she's followed Common Sense which
is what we talk about everything we
teach yeah yeah very very cool stuff
very impressive very impressive so this
is like when someone uh gets a big life
insurance check after their spouse dies
it's the same thing I want you to I I
want that fear that that broken heart to
motivate you to go slowly yeah and to
make good wise careful decisions same
kind of a thing there and man she just
did a great job with that just amazing
very very cool I love it ah Ah that's
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pods for
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Jade wash all
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and Chris starts
this hour in Boston hey Chris how are
you
great how's it going Dave better than we
deserve what's up
hey so really appreciate you taking my
call I uh over the last four years I
entered a job wherein I was able to
make commission checks and save up quite
a nice bit of money and I just I'm
looking to get your advice having
recently started your program and you
see what I should do with the money I
have and any future money that I get
so are you setting aside is I'm guessing
this is 1099 type money
no this is so I work in Enterprise sales
I get commissions that get taxed at a 35
um I take home the 65 so are you on a
budget
I am not on a budget per se I uh I
basically I have my three to six month
emergency fund already done so I have
15K
set aside and I currently have 60
000 in my savings account and I'm
expecting a hundred and fifty thousand
in July from a deal that I just closed
very good so uh are you renting are you
interested in purchasing a house let's
think about what the next steps are
absolutely so I'm renting I definitely
am looking in the next year or so to
start getting into the housing market
um and the only debt that I currently
have outside of that potential mortgage
is 38 000 in student loans okay and I
know that I need to wipe that out yeah
you can do that with the 60k that's
sitting around the extra 60k you could
do that today yeah yeah I know not good
will right
Chris uh the nervous laugh makes me
cringe
don't be nervous laughter you have sixty
thousand dollars write a check today and
pay off get it done do it right now
right now they're not going to get
forgiven well is not a pet she's an evil
woman thanks
and this is real it's not going to get
forgiven pay it off and then move on
with your life move on with your life
and then let's start thinking about how
old are you
I'm 32. you've done a really good job
Chris okay uh any problem what are you
what would you say the probability is
that you are married in the next 24 to
36 months
[Music]
okay all right so there's not like a
there's not like a thing in the offing
that I'm not talking about yet okay all
right cool in that case buy a house now
what I would tell you is buy a home as a
single guy in uh at your age that is not
a uh a specialty home buy a home that's
a little bit vanilla boring easy to
resell
because if you were to get married you
will discover you have bought the wrong
home
okay she's gonna make you move okay
exactly yeah that I I agree
wholeheartedly with Dave's advice don't
buy you know this perfect home that you
think it's great that you're thinking oh
one of these days I was very relating
it's going to be our family home no no
he's exactly right whoever you marry
she's gonna go if you guys let's do
something else exactly if you can resell
it easily you'll make a lot of money on
it and that's what I want you to buy for
your first one here in your stage of
life in your current demographic and
everything that's what I would do if I
were your age but you're doing great man
the obvious thing is you're making a lot
of money and you've not been crazy with
it uh so pay off your student loan have
your emergency fund at your mark
everything Beyond three to six months of
expenses for your down payment pile up a
huge down payment don't take out more
than a 15-year fixed where the payment
is more than a fourth of your take-home
pay and buy something that's a little
bit vanilla not too fancy schmancy and
it's going to be easy to resell it's
going to have a large Market when you
get ready to resell it a lot of people
are going to want this property which
will make it go up faster and easier to
sell both that's what the the summation
of this call is so very very well done
wow he did good he did do good he's got
a lot of money coming in a lot of Cash
Money serious bucks hey guys we
appreciate all of you listening thank
you we do not have 300 million a year to
spend on Advertising around here uh we
don't have a football stadium named
after us who did that like uh so far
yeah and so uh you got to help us if you
want to help us uh you you spread the
word you subscribe to the show you
follow the show on YouTube or podcast
you share the show on YouTube podcasts
or share that you're listening to it on
talk radio or watching it on TBN
whatever is share to spread the word and
if you're in a situation where you can
leave a five-star review we don't need
one Stars mama said if you ain't got
nothing nice to say don't say anything
at all okay move on if you hate us what
the devil you're doing listening that's
weird it's just weird so move on because
it's not gonna change I'll just tell you
that yeah your one star review is not
going to change anything so move on do
your five stars turn them in follow
let everybody know we're out here it's
really really helpful we really really
really really really appreciate it now
here's the thing Jade let's talk about
real estate for just a second sure
buying real estate
over the scope of your life with a
long-term view when you are not broke
anymore is a good plan
people in our culture have translated
that and truncated that to say that no
matter what stage of life you're in no
matter how broke you are everyone should
immediately go out and buy real estate
that is not true Real Estate For Broke
people is a curse
yeah it changes a blessing to a burden
and that's what's the whole point
buying a home when you have a big
student loan debt when you've got car
payments coming out your ears when
you're spending like you're in Congress
you got Master Card and American
distress in your life
and you got all this crap going on and
then you go buy a house like that's
gonna that's like having a bad marriage
and thinking you're going to have kids
is going to fix it exactly well yeah
it's not the solution and it just
creates less and less margin and less
and less
um room for anything to go wrong because
when you do that if one thing goes wrong
Dave just a little no think win yeah not
if yeah that's true when that one thing
goes wrong welcome to life boys and
girls crap's gonna happen it's a bumper
sticker to that effect I think so you
know really it's gonna happen and so if
you don't have any margin you know the
hot water heater goes out all of a
sudden you're having to choose between
hot water and Sallie Mae horrible bad
choice and so you put yourself in the
corner because everybody's got to get
real estate everybody's got to get real
no you don't
get yourself out of debt have an
emergency fund have a good down payment
Be steady on the job
smooth Rhythm here
not Herky jerky not all over the place
very calm
it's okay if it takes a little while
right okay now you don't want to be a
renderer your entire life so make the
steps to get to being not broke anymore
but this idea real estate fixes
everything no it doesn't well people
think it's a quick quick writ get rid
and get rich quick off of real estate
they become so desperate it's their only
way out and it's actually not a way out
it's a way in to the problems this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
wash and guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining us Jade warshaw
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
if you're just listening to the show
trying to piece together what we teach
on your own I mean you can watch 500
YouTubes if you want and try to figure
it all out or you could just go through
instead of figuring out the individual
puzzle pieces actually go see the whole
picture which is Financial Peace
University and it's all real simple and
laid out and in nine lessons you'll have
the whole system done and rolling and
you could be done like in any two years
instead of four or five years wandering
around trying to do your own puzzle I
mean yeah it's out there Dave all your
stuff's out there for free honey my
stuff was out there for free before it
was mine
it's called common sense
I stole it all from God and your
grandmother I didn't invent any of this
I'm just really good at packaging it and
convincing you people to do it
so you know yeah Financial Peace
University though is the proven system
that will help you get going in a faster
rate and uh you're going to move out of
debt the typical person moves out of
debt in 18 to 24 months not counting
their house and that goes through
Financial Peace University so this is
everything you need in one place it's a
community of people that love you and
hold you accountable and encourage you
when you're scared and push you and push
you and say quit trying to do your own
plan because your own plan sucks that's
why you're here
you need a new plan
a better plan a faster plan a more
Proven Plan 10 million people been
through Financial Peace University and
the majority are debt free in less than
two years so we're pouring some jet fuel
on this whole thing because here's what
we're going to do
all of the Ramsey personalities
including the one to my right Jade
warshaw is going to be leading you
personally through an FPU class if you
want to buy an FPU right now you can
join Ken Coleman's class Dr John
deloney's class Jade washer Eddie Cullen
and Rachel Cruz's class Jade and
Rachel's class starts on Monday
yes and we just got a few spots left
that's right sign up and and you have to
sign up before Monday don't think you
know oh I'll sign up later and I'll be
gone yeah or you know a lot of people
think if they sign up later they can
attend you know maybe starting in the
later weeks but no it'll close the sign
ups will close so sign up and uh you
need this you need it because what you
weren't doing what you were doing wasn't
working and I will kick your butt and I
will do it with with gusto and and love
and love she's sweet there's a little
bit of love in there but it's mostly we
she just she thinks she's mean yeah it's
like a pit bull yeah you know you'll be
nice you'll be nice they're sweet and
lovable once you get to know them
they'll be tears but you'll enjoy them
no kidding Hey listen you gotta have
somebody in your corner going we love
you you got we want you to win and
that's us so go to ramseysolutions.com
sign up for Financial Peace University
you can try fpu.com if you want to sign
up in one of these personality classes
and join Rachel or Jades or George's or
kilman's or delonies or whatever yeah
these classes will all be full and
they're gonna be these guys are having a
little competition among themselves so
this could be pretty fun behind the
scenes and we might actually tell you
like who's winning or something which is
why you need to sign up for my class
your class yeah well you're here so
there you go that's it that's how this
works so um
another uh another dumb dumb dumb dumb
thing out there huh it's like just when
I think we've covered the Pinnacle
our guys and uh first
and Dave yet again he locks are all the
rage and it's it's not enough that you
can you know pull the equity on your
home now they've turned it into a whole
thing this is called the Avon credit
card but it's not like all the other
credit cards Dave because those other
credit cards they're bad bad they're
unsecured dead wouldn't it be nice to
have one that's secured debt yeah so
when you buy a steak you can't afford
at the restaurant
you lose your home oh there you go
because you pledged collateral I a stake
for your home nice trade and that's what
they're saying they're saying what
wouldn't it be nice to have a credit
card that lets you use your home equity
to get really low rates it lets you this
is a privilege Dave that we so sweet of
them they're so service minded and I
love that it says you get really really
low rates between
7.99 and 14.99 variable interest
better than a credit card is it
you know one of these credit card rating
service people called and wanted me to
comment on a thing the other day and our
PR team went um did you get a wrong
number
because Dave's credit card has a zero
interest he doesn't have a credit card
that's the rate on mine zero interest
debit card
that's all I use
I haven't had a credit card since 1988.
because to start with we filed
bankruptcy they wouldn't give us one
and then later but we also made the
decision we weren't borrowing money ever
again for any reason and we walked
around in a non-debit card Society for a
little while with no credit cards and
that was tough I bet it was yeah I flew
to New York and couldn't check into a
hotel it was ridiculous wow I mean I I
no matter how much cash I flashed they
wouldn't let me in it was crazy so wow
yeah it was a problem now you got debit
cards does everything credit card does
so uh and except charge you 7.9 interest
on your home equity loan what if you
lost your mind people
but you don't think Dave that it's worth
it to leverage your home for 1.5
unlimited cash back unlimited unlimited
so let me get this straight
I pay out
a hundred dollars
and I get back
a dollar fifty yes
you know what I'm gonna get rich trading
a hundred for a dollar fifty and that's
what needs to be called out that's I
that's that's just so much wisdom in
that I mean everyone knows when you
trade 100 for a dollar fifty you're
going to Bill wealth quickly yeah it's
the idiocy it's unlimited unlimited cash
stupidity is unlimited
first part here here's here's worst part
um you only need as much as five
thousand dollars equity in your home
and they're willing to give you that on
a line of credit on the even credit card
they're just amazingly they're just
kindest crocodiles the whole the whole
point in buying the home part of it was
to build wealth but you're pulling the
wealth out and here's the thing y'all
didn't see the commercial for this in
the commercial they're swiping the Avon
card for books
in a jewelry store in a clothing store
that's what they're using their home
equity on that's what people are using
this money for yours your you're trading
your freedom and your wealth
for
shirts but you take a dollar fifty back
out of every hundred
I don't want to hear anybody complaining
about the state of their finances if
anybody is willing to get on board with
if you're willing to get on the board
with things like this don't come
complaining and don't come crying to me
this is terrible and you heard it first
here these are bad bad bad ideas Dave
they're bad
what you I can't even say it's marketing
the marketing is so pleasant it seems so
reasonable it calls it a credit card up
front home equity in the back
it's a mullet it's a money mullet
what does that mean all business up
front a party in the back yes
with 14.99 added pain and regret that's
all for me Mitchell mullet
[Laughter]
it has a new name it's called Avon yes
the financial
buck and a half it's going to cost you
you'll get that back for every 100 you
spend you get a dollar and a half back
you go and get your mullet and
they're going to give you spend 100
bucks you're gonna give you a buck and a
half back in a mullet oh gosh I love it
that's it that's exactly the line it's
exactly the line a credit card up front
a home equity loan in the back
just all business up front and a party
in the back oh oh gosh I cannot make
this crap up you can't
ad agencies very good lord it's just
well you can get it in as fast as 15
minutes does that make us feel any
better
just makes me feel better because I've
got a long career I know that's all
stupids out there I'm gonna be around
job security
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
wow
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host so Vic Keller who's going to be
on the entree leadership podcast in a
few weeks he's the president of
Christiansen arms just dropped me off a
6.5 read more
rifle pretty freaking incredible
so I'm kind of I'm kind of stunned right
this second it's absolutely a work of
art it's absolutely beautiful rifle so
anyway back to business here back to
business I'm going to come down out of
the clouds for a second enjoy the ride
Dennis and Cameron with us on the debt
free stage hey guys how are you doing
great Dave welcome where do you all live
Raleigh North Carolina Fun how much debt
have you paid off four hundred and
twenty thousand dollars how long did
this take five and a half years I love
it and your range of income during that
time so it was a 150 000 all the way up
to 300 000. whoa what do you all do for
a living
so I work in procurement for a clinical
research organization cool Dave I've
worked for a faith-based wealth
management firm called Steward wealth
strategies where I'm a wealth manager
yeah and a Dave Ramsey smart investor
Pro awesome okay very cool so 420 000
great income great careers five and a
half years I'm gonna guess and say you
might have paid off your house yes sir
let's go
what's the house worth about 650 000.
all right wealth manager how much have
you gotten your nest egg
nest egg is right around 550
000. so young young millionaires how old
are you two I'm 36. and just turned 42
yesterday oh my goodness yeah great way
to go very cool very cool how long you
all been married five and a half years
oh okay so there's the story all right
so what happened what was the story here
yeah so I'll start
um so I'd actually never heard of you
Dave before meeting Dennis and um uh oh
thankfully when we met and started
dating we both really weren't bringing
too much debt to the table he'd been
doing your program for a couple of years
and I just had the mortgage on the house
that I bought before meeting Dennis
um I actually I did ROTC through college
I worked through college I got out of
school with no student loans which was
huge and
um I had never taken out a credit card I
think I was just dead averse to begin
with yeah um but when we got engaged he
was coordinating an FPU class and asked
if I would come and that's what I love
it first checkbook that's right it
opened up my eyes to the fact that even
I wasn't drowning in debt but I also I'd
never sat down and written down a budget
if you ask me what I was spending every
month I couldn't have told you so it I
was just floating I was getting by with
my money but I wasn't working towards
any true goals is this your general
Spirit of being deadaverse kept you kept
you in the zone of wisdom luckily I
wasn't drowning yeah very good but yeah
so it definitely got us talking and
saying when we get married this is what
we want to do this is where we want to
be but yeah Dennis had been on the
journey before meeting me yeah so so
Dave so I uh similar to Kim worked
through college I had scholarships so
got out with uh with no debt but then
soon became normal early into my career
so living paycheck to paycheck no
emergency fund just no plan whatsoever I
had six credit cards I'm very popular
with them so that was great they liked
it oh they loved me so uh Max those out
but then finally uh you know after years
of being on the edge a friend of mine
gave me Total Money Makeover within a
weekend I read through it and was just
bound and determined that Yep this is
how it's gonna this is this is the right
way to do this so started doing my
budget actually uh projected out on a
spreadsheet all the baby steps and uh
even bought a hoopty so I love my uh my
hoopty but show them how did y'all buy
the house after you got married or you
already had it when you got married so I
had a house it was a much smaller house
and then we bought a bigger one we've
got three boys so we we did upgrade the
house and that's the one that we just
paid off ah okay all right very good so
you sold the old one yeah you had before
yep bought a new one in five and a half
years later paid it off yes sir perfect
wow so I have a question plenty of
people are like yeah I gotta pay off my
debt plenty of people might be willing
to downgrade their car to pay off their
debt but I mean you guys were like we're
going all in to pay off our home what
was it I mean what was the why behind
that that made you go you know to this
extent
I mean it's that that was just the uh
the plan and so we figured that right
now while we while our kids are young uh
while we had this income that this is
what we're going to focus on and that
was really a challenge of everything
that was going on of uh of folks asking
us hey why aren't you upgrading your
cars why aren't you guys upgrading the
house why aren't you guys going on
trips or anything like that we're like
nope we're just focused this is what
we're gonna do we know this is a season
and so uh that's just what we do people
call you all a couple nerds for sure
one of our bigger whys has been been
this firmer marriage Foundation because
we did this from day one of getting
married I mean to the extent that on our
honeymoon we were driving there Dennis
had me writing out our very first
combined monthly budget together he's
not excited to get started it was the
height of Finance for sure so so yeah he
was a super Stone Cold romance
but now looking back I feel I mean I'm
so thankful that we started off the
marriage that way because it's so good I
recommend it to anybody who's almost
getting married newly married whatever
you weren't 19. no I mean you were 32
and 37 right
yeah approximately yeah yeah wow wow wow
amazing that's so funny so well now uh
I guess when you're meeting with clients
now it's a completely different
conversation than it hey I'm 42. I got a
net worth of over a million dollars I
got a paid for house I've been married
five years yep and all you gotta do is
follow the stuff exactly and that's
exactly that's the what we tell folks to
do is to follow the baby steps and so
that's what we do so uh I mean it's it's
absolutely uh that's a great feeling so
Kim around the company when you're doing
procurement and you're interacting with
your leadership team and so forth
someone says how'd you do that what do
you tell them the key to getting out of
debt is oh man I I do think it is around
well he has the more tactical answers
because he is definitely the numbers guy
who's I guess the nerd of your system
but I think for me it was it was finding
that y That's bigger than just me and
you know we had three kids that added to
the mix along the way they were huge
drivers for us we really want them to
see that you know when we say God is
first in our lives they're seeing that
live out in how we spend our money also
now we're in a position where we can be
outrageously generous like you talk
about so you know we're hoping they're
going to witness that growing up and
it's gonna ultimately impact their
eternities too yeah wow fabulous very
cool well done you don't have a payment
in the world
how's that feel
hasn't sunk in yet tomorrow is when the
mortgage payment was supposed to go out
and so we don't know exactly how it
feels yet so and so literally yeah we're
surprised yeah so you already sent it
but it's correct hadn't gotten you
haven't gotten the stuff back yet
correct oh tomorrow would have been the
the first this is the first month of
Freedom oh wow so cool now I understand
okay wow exciting man
yeah so what's the first big thing y'all
want to do now that you're free
yeah I think there's you know there's a
couple things we've been putting off we
both drive 12 plus year old cars we
squeezed
cars we've got you know an unfinished
basement and three boys so that's going
to be a worthy investment to finish out
the basement so things we're excited
about but you'll knock out you'll knock
both those things out in your heartbeat
I know now we can cash flow everything
by Christmas so on on the way to the
honeymoon you had to write down the
budget now on the way home from here you
get to write down all the things that
you already said that he's like the
plane ride home we're going to be doing
them yeah we're doing the budget we're
doing this so fun goals yeah yeah what
comes first the car or the basement yeah
or Mommy gets a car then we do this yeah
minivan or SUV he's team minivan but
wow interesting interesting all right
uh I think she gets to pick her car
there we go dude I'm just saying well
she can pick hers and then he can pick
his that's me this is fair there you go
there yeah yeah team minivan
right up there with Rachel Cruz I love
it all right guys hey we've got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you
you've already done that you can hand it
to a client Total Money Makeover you
already done that you can hand it to a
client and Financial Peace University
you've already done that and you can
hand it to a client or you can go back
through all of them again it's all it's
the live and give box it's just for you
to say thank you for coming out Dennis
and Kim Raleigh North Carolina 420 000
paid off five and a half years five and
a half years of marriage making 150 to
300 100 debt free house and everything
baby steps millionaires come
let's hear a dead free scream three two
one
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah baby I love that this is how it's
done boys and girls
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today Mike is
in Mississippi hey Mike what's up
hey Dave hey Jade thank you for all that
you do and thank you for taking this
call sure how can we help
I've got a opportunity that I think is a
sweet deal but I'm wanting to get a gut
check on if I'm missing something or or
just not seeing something but I want to
give you a little bit of background I I
went to entree leadership back in
September
um I hit baby step seven in August
and I also teach financial peace now so
fully fully aware of every you know
where I am and everything that God's
given me so very cool congratulations
I'm uh thank you I've got a a um I'm
self-employed I'm a town architect which
is basically uh I work in developments
and communities to uh to design and and
build them up I don't do the building
personally I just work with the owners
and the builders to to get them where
they need to be and for the last two
years I've been working with an owner to
um to really push this neighborhood and
Community forward and I've had projects
all along the way that I've gotten paid
for but I've also done a lot of Sweat
Equity in tons of meetings and just
going with the owner to see see places
and and do things and never send in an
invoice I've got a guy on the owner team
who has kind of recognized that and we
were talking I had a meeting yesterday
on between meetings and that's why I'm
calling you at a meeting yesterday with
him and I have another meeting next week
we talked yesterday about uh he would he
would like and I would like to move my
my architect office to the neighborhood
uh the next slated thing to do in the
neighborhood is a series of cottages
there are thousand to 1250 square feet
and my office would fit I'm a small
office so it would fit right in there
with it and I would be part of the
neighborhood they kind of like that
having a town architect part of the
neighborhood I kind of like it too so we
got to talking you know how do we get
this done and how do we make it happen
and uh I told him I said well I don't do
anything with debt so uh we you know we
really have to figure this out
so you know my numbers I've got about a
hundred thousand in retained earnings
I've got 75
000 as a savings actually we me and my
wife actually jumped back to 3B and I've
got 75 000 for a future home
um this time you don't own a home just
my office you don't own a home that
hello you don't own a home
no I do own a home I just I have an
upgrade home in the future yeah so we're
yeah so we're saving for an upgrade home
in the future
um this is just a cottage that will be
my office but it will actually be a
cottage that okay so what's the deal
what's the deal
so the deal is we talked about him
giving needs a lot for a dollar I paid I
pay a dollar for the lot and I would be
about half in on the construction of the
home they would actually pay the Builder
pay the Builder fees and all that stuff
for the rest of it so I might be about
60 to 75 70 000 out of my pocket
the um I told him that sounded really
good I've got a a mixed-use building
that I did they're going to give you
everything but sixty thousand dollars
yeah and you've got 175 000. where's the
problem you're just going to pay cash
for the sixty thousand
yeah so what's the downside
that's my retained earnings what's your
what's the cottage going to be worth
when it's done
um I would guess that when it's done
about two hundred thousand okay so you
come up with 60 Grand and you have a 200
000 asset ding ding ding ding no-brainer
do it and you have the cash you have the
cash yeah and it's all in your name
yeah no partnership yeah I mean no debt
yeah I made that I made that part of the
stipulation yeah no debt no partnership
no nothing they're just they're just
giving you a really nice gift uh of
their Sweat Equity in return in
recognition of you've done a bunch of
work you didn't get paid for
yeah I love it that's great do it
okay even if you sell it later I mean
what you know but you've got you have
175 000 use some of that buy this thing
and then here's here's actually how I'm
going to pay for it I did a mixed-use
building for the owner and about halfway
through we were estimating five and a
half million dollars for the for the
thing and I'd get a percentage fee while
you know price increases and everything
over the last year that was a year ago
it's now at nine million dollars and so
I'm pushing them also a stipulation I
would do this if they go ahead forward
and finish the last half of the drawings
and get it to go under construction at
which case my feed jumps and I just pay
for this out of the fee gel well there
you go this is a
yeah I think you've got this from six
different angles big down this thing's
beat down to nothing absolutely you have
to do it yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
make sure all the paperwork and
contracts and everything's in writing
exactly the deal is laid out in detail
and that you walk away with clean title
and you don't walk away with something
that you know is in perpetuation that
you owe these people percentage of
equity or something crap back or
something like that yeah it's a clean
deal very clean exciting Chop Chop good
job very well done very well done Lisa
is in Bowling Green Kentucky hi Lisa
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi thank you
for taking my call my question involves
baby step four uh my husband and I we've
got a sophomore in high school and we've
got about 25 000 already in a 529 for
her so but we're so we recognize we're a
little behind maybe five is kids college
okay all right yes okay we're making
sure I understood what you're doing okay
yes five
five I'm gonna be receiving some money
soon for being an executor of a family
members of the state and after tithing
taxes and finishing out baby step three
which would be about ten thousand
dollars for baby step three uh we're
gonna have about fifteen thousand
dollars remaining and my question is
with only two years left to go before
college should we put some of that in
the 529 or is it best just to put it in
a high-yield savings account no I'll
just dumping that 529. it's fine it's in
good mutual funds isn't it
just dump it in there and then plan on
trying to cash flow the first year or
something and leave that alone let it
ride
true well and we have another child that
is currently in college and I think with
that that one is going to be cash flow
with our 529 for that child and I think
there might be a little left over
because she plans to graduate early so
it's great yeah I would just hate it
when that happens I know
very good good job Hey listen let me
tell you what you're doing this very
smart
that 98 of Americans do not do
you are doing your kids college
intentionally
you actually thought about it it didn't
happen to you guys you happened to it
you were proactive yeah you clearly
chose colleges that were affordable that
were within means of your family to pay
cash for or save up to pay for and
that's right there that right there is
half the battle plenty of people don't
do that so the fact that you're being
wise about that and you're able to send
your kids to college probably ex you
know paying cash for it is incredible
yeah be encouraged you are weird in a
good way well thank you you're good kind
of weird very great very very well done
so you know we used to say years ago 98
of the people that you interview say
it's important to say for college and
two percent of the people do it yeah
everybody says it's important it always
comes to the doing that's the hard part
the doing everybody says this is
important you should do it yes we know
this is important but when the rubber
meets the road few people actually do
what it takes to take that money aside I
mean she's receiving this money how many
people would have just blown it 15K I'm
gonna well I need a new car bought
something for thirty thousand yeah put
15 down on it yeah yeah or or said well
I've got this this allows people
forced to take out student loans
because we bought daddy a pickup
that's a crap that people do right there
that's the language I was forced to do I
didn't have a choice like they had a gun
and duct tape yeah when people say I
didn't have a choice you weren't forced
you just straight up chose stupid you
just chose it said I love stupid I'm
gonna embrace it that's right I did it I
know what it looks like like stupid as
your best friend or something oh my God
yeah you weren't forced to do anything
drama to justify your stupidity I know
because I have a drama queen that lives
in me too so this is how this works what
do you call her Dave
David lean yes sir
this is the Ramsay show
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Maggie starts this hour off in Seattle
hey Maggie how are you
I'm great Dave
better than I deserve what's up
so I'm currently a junior in high school
I am enrolled in a program at my local
community college that will allow me to
graduate high school with my high school
diploma as well as my associate's degree
and I'm not paying tuition for it
because I'm still in high school so I've
been able to pay for my first two years
of college with cash just going through
it I work a little I work as much as I
can
um and so that's my dumb girl you're a
genius
yeah it's a pretty great program I'm
really happy I taught you to do this
how'd you figure this out
the program and they said I didn't have
to pay tuition the first day sign me up
who's they the college
well my high school really recommends it
because that's great smaller Cooperative
yeah so they recommend doing it so
you're not paying tuition so yeah it's a
great deal you know it's really just
cost of books or whatever so you were
smart enough to take that deal good for
you yeah yeah thank you so my dream for
the future in a career would really to
be owning my own LLC in the trades I
love the trades I love working with my
hands I love kind of the job security
and I love entrepreneurship my dad
himself owns a small business and so
I've just I've seen the ups and downs
and it's a path that I think I would
really like to take um and when you say
the trades what do you mean
idea
idea my dad does a created very
specifically so I think I do more broad
construction
potentially maybe Roofing just something
that is a constant need at least until
robots replace us but as far as I'm
concerned for now I just would really
like to do potentially construction or
Roofing and that's a pretty big hit in
my small town in Washington so that's
something I'd like to pursue and so
because of that my dad you know doing
his trade he has lots of colleagues that
have done and very very very successful
businessmen and so my biggest question
for you is I'm at that age where I have
to start preparing and kind of signing
up for college and doing all of that and
college is just kind of something I
figured I would do until I got older and
I started understanding finances and I
started understanding how detrimental
debt can be and I just really it's been
weighing on me if that's not where I
want to be and I have some family
members who did the college route and
you know they are
quite a bit in depth and I just I don't
know I just don't want that to be me in
only a lot two years
yeah yeah two years but the problem is
is that they tell you it's going to be
two years and then you go to sign up for
it and then they require a bunch of
other classes
yeah
have you actually gone and had that
experience
to a university yeah looked at your
career your Associates and it won't
cover the first two years
if I go so specifically there's a local
University that I would really like to
look at their business administration
and Entrepreneurship program and they
require a bunch of prereqs you have to
satisfy the pre-major in order to
declare that as your major and some of
those classes of Community College
doesn't offer so I would have to go take
that year so it really wouldn't be two
years it'd be three so go to a different
School
that doesn't have all those requirements
okay why are you trapped you're not
trapped I think you need to do a little
more research to see what institutions
will accept your community college
classes and and start you out in your
junior year and find a place that's
inexpensive and you can pay cash for two
more years and good Lord you're going to
be a whole 19 years old when you
graduate from college yeah don't don't
College because you're afraid of debt
College without debt
debt okay you know what I'm saying and I
kind of hurt my neck I heard you saying
that and I I don't want you to make that
choice based on fear I want you to make
that choice based on if you would like
to go to college you can go to college
and work and pay for it if you choose
the right school does that make sense
yeah let me let's expect this roll back
just a second okay you've got an
associate's degree not because
uh because you agreed to go to a school
that allowed you to do that
right you could have chosen another
school and you would have put in the
same amount of time and not come out
with an associate's degree
but you you conceded that this school
allowed me to have this situation so I
want you to concede again
and find a school that allows you to
graduate in just two more years it was a
simple with a simple business degree or
a marketing degree or or whatever
something like that and here's why okay
here's the reason I'm pushing this it's
not because all education is good and
all education is necessary it's not but
you said to me you want to run a
business all right now here's what
happens in the trades we work in entree
leadership with Tradesmen of all kinds
roofers heat and air people uh Builders
General Contractors remodelers we get
thousands of these guys I've worked with
I grew up in the business in the
building business my parents were in the
building business so I know the business
here's what happens
you get a guy or in your case a gal who
knows a trade let's say you know how to
put on a roof and you know how to run a
roofing crew
and so you're a good roofer but that
enables you to put on roofs right that
does not enable you to run a business
there it is correct yeah okay running a
business is a different skill and
knowledge base than putting on a roof
the business happens to be putting on
roofs but what happens is a guy's in the
he works for heating and air company for
five or six years and then he says hey
I've got all my licenses I know how to
fix any kind of heating and air I can
just go open up my own Heating and
everything which is true he can and
probably should go do that but then he
grows the business and has six people
working for him now he has this
leadership issues right now he has
accounting issues now he has marketing
issues now he has administrative issues
and Licensing issues and none of that
has anything to do with fixing a heat
and air
right right but it has to do with
running a business so as bright as you
are and as much of a head start as you
got I would say get a basic business
degree that puts those tools to run the
business in your business tool belt and
then you also know how to do Roofing if
that's the side you're going to go into
and you're managing a roofing crew and
you know about roofs and you know about
the different uh applications whether
it's commercial application with a flat
roof and rubber or whether it's asphalt
shingle on a residential or whatever I
mean you know you're going to learn all
of these things that are specific to
that trade but the trade is different
than running a business that is so Dave
you hit the nail on the head oh see what
I did there I saw what you said oh you
hit the you really did hit the nail on
the head because it happens all the time
you you get in contact with these guys
and you're like can you come do the work
for me and it's like all of the business
stuff surrounding it it just
it just Falls to Pieces yeah you know
because you can feel there doesn't mean
you need to own a salon the billing the
correspondence doesn't mean you need to
run a restaurant I know that's right but
Maggie is cool Maggie is smart he is
amazing yeah she's she's a good one you
do know the roofing nail there's a
particularly large head
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today well it's here it's here
Dave one of my favorite things to do is
give away your money did you know that
spiritual gift you have that's right I'm
super excited to tell our listeners that
we're giving away 500 every week with a
grand prize of three thousand dollars in
May this is our Ramsay cash giveaway
this is fun wow and no purchase
necessary got to be 18 and you can enter
up two once a day if you enter more than
that the computer throws you out so give
it a shot though come to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway and uh
while you're there celebrate the uh ten
dollar special with you uh with us that
means that all of our number one
best-selling books and number two
best-selling books are on sale for ten
dollars yeah ten dollar holla yeah
that's it man so Dr John deloney's on
your pass change your future uh Ken
Coleman's paycheck to purpose uh my
latest baby steps millionaires of course
Total Money Makeover ten dollars each
that means you get like 10 books for 100
bucks wow we are giving your money away
a deal that's a deal it's a serious deal
ten dollar sale does not last forever
this is the month of May with a 500
giveaway every week and a three thousand
dollar grand prize at the end no
purchases necessary check out the ten
dollar sale at ramseysolutions.com by
the way a reminder that Mike Rowe is in
the house wow and uh he and I will be
doing an event tonight at the Ramsey
live event center on the hill right
behind me America's labor crisis with
five of the leading experts on what is
going on with work
in America today
it's a completely free live stream here
on Star Wars Day May the 4th be with you
and so go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on the live stream and watch it
with us tonight we would love to have
you we'll have about a thousand of our
closest friends and our audience there
hanging out with us and watching this
and Mike is just brilliant and uh as are
these five folks we've got coming on and
I'm just honored to be a wiener in a
steakhouse it's going to be amazing so
let's get with it
ramseysolutions.com and America's labor
crisis if you are struggling with the
philosophy of work in America today
you're trying to hire people right now
you're running a business you know what
you're up against it's the hardest
toughest labor market we've ever been in
in the history of America right now
really this is pretty amazing so we
actually have a negative unemployment
rate 4 000 people a month quitting their
jobs she it's crazy out there so we're
going to talk about it and talk about
some solutions for you business folk you
leadership leadership folk out there so
join us again ramseysolutions.com
America's labor crisis tonight the
question of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services if
you own rental properties neighborly's
local Real Property Management offices
can help you manage them and optimize
your Roi and your peace of mind to go to
neighborly.com to schedule a
consultation with Real Property
Management Pros near you all right
today's question comes from Sarah in
Maryland she says my husband and I will
open a new business soon and this is our
very first restaurant we've been waiting
for this opportunity for a long time and
once we open we plan to divide our focus
with my husband focusing on our next
goal of opening a second business and I
will then focus on our family goals of
having a kid and buying a house will
this plan work or should we wait for the
second business to be open first to have
a kid and buy a house
Lord all right
um there's a lot going on here
um I'm gonna warn you Sarah I'm gonna
give you some good advice and I hope you
don't mistake it for dream crushing
because that's not what I'm going for
here I think that you've got a lot of
major
things that you're trying to focus on
these are made I mean you're starting a
business it doesn't say here Dave if
these are cash businesses but something
tells me they're probably not
and that scares me I think you guys need
to pick
one thing to focus on now
here comes a little bit of dream
crushing
you've just you've just
opened this restaurant business and I I
don't want to say this but sixty percent
of restaurants fail in the first year
so let's not open a second business yet
and that's why that's one of the many
reasons why and 80 fail in five years so
I want to put those stats out there you
probably already know that but I wanted
to let you know that and then you're
talking about a house you're talking
about kids I don't know if you have debt
or not
um it doesn't tell us here but you are
trying to float a lot of boats right now
in a bathtub and it is not working so I
think you need to focus I
I wouldn't want to be in your shoes it's
so much it's so much to juggle yeah do
one thing and
if if owning a business has always been
your dream there's a right way to do
that all right and I I'm gonna walk you
through what I think if it were Jade
what the steps would be
to doing that if you guys have got
number one I want you to do the business
in cash with when it comes to
restaurants that's going to be very
difficult but you can do it and it's
probably going to start with you getting
your personal finances in line first so
that you can do this and so if you have
any debt you're going to need to pay off
that debt I'd want you to walk through
our baby steps which you know we'll put
the information there on the screen uh
for the baby steps you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and get that
information that's thing one getting
your personal finances in place because
for most of us if we want to start our
own business we think oh it's business
money it's no it's your personal money
it takes your personal money to start a
business there's no uh magical cloud of
business money that appears when it's
time to start a business so that's thing
one get your money under control and
then if look if starting a restaurant is
what you want to do you've got to get a
plan in action for how you're going to
do that in cash now in the midst of that
if you have kids all of that having the
kids is not the problem buying a home
that might present a problem because
that's expensive we gotta save for a
down payment for that so it's really
going to be you guys deciding if you're
going to get on a plan if you're going
to use our plan because the way our plan
is going to do it you're going to have
to go through these baby steps maybe in
order to do it so that's how that works
you're going to increase
your probability of failure
10x hmm
about trying to do 73 things at once
you're gonna suck at all of them
because you're not gonna be paying
enough attention to them
this is an add plan right here squirrel
yeah you know and so you've gotta you
gotta just restaurant business is hard
yeah hard work long hours
so much physically draining
focus on the restaurant business
get it up and running
nothing else
it's going to take all you got you're
going to leave it all on the field to
get that restaurant profitable and get
it running if you don't want to run a
restaurant then sell it
get it up and running and sell it but
don't open a second business
I run one business
other guys that have my net worth
put money in all these other Venture
Capital deals Dave you need to you need
to buy into this you need to buy into
that you need to buy into this and if I
did that I would have my eyes on all of
those things instead of on Ramsey and
Ramsay would not be here
the reason Ramsay's here is I do one
thing Dave you're a one-trick pony yep
and I'm an expert trick pony okay
Specialists do nothing else
complete laser
Focus that's so important right that is
focused will do surgery cut metal when
it's dispersed it simply lights a room
come on that's so good you know yeah
focus focus then have your babies
get your house later
and if you want a second business sell
the restaurant before you open the
second one what you said Dave is a good
point I think that and this is not an
insult this is just the truth few people
can do one thing one thing yeah well
almost no one almost that's why we all
stand back and go well that's guys
successful that woman is successful
because they do one thing well and
anything anything more is you're a
unicorn right and there's very very very
very very very very few of those those
are very rare now I'm just don't exist
I'm just a wiener in a steakhouse maybe
I don't know what I'm talking about but
that was wonderful classic line yeah the
seriously you've got a lot of energy
honey and you're you're a sharp young
woman and sometimes the best thing you
can do is be just a little bit Dumber
so that all you can do is do one thing
thank God I'm not smart enough to do 63
things because I probably would not got
any of them done they got it required
children and restaurants require all of
your energy this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
personalities my co-host Julie Is With
Us in Springfield Missouri hi Julie how
are you
better than I deserve what's up
um so we've pulled our house back in
August and we are still sitting on the
money that we got back from it
um so my question is should we throw all
that money toward the debt
um and could we use part of it as a down
payment for a house or should we put it
all on today how much money do you have
seventeen thousand and how much debt do
you have
23 7. and what's your household income
50 and we're we're around 90 now good
for you okay
and where are you living now
we are actually in a camper we bought a
used fifth wheel whenever we sold our
house so we're going a little crazy we
have two kids and two dogs and a 40 foot
camper so how old are yeah uh I'm 28 my
husband's 32. why'd you show your house
okay
um 17K from the home sale
um
23.7 a day are you currently working
this snowball have you started paying
off other debts yet
we haven't no okay do you have a
thousand dollars saved
we do okay that's only three thousand
that's true so we'll start with a
thousand dollars saved I I guess what
I'm looking for I want to make sure that
you're committed to a process going
forward
because it's going to take you being
committed to this process or else you're
going to go she told me to take this
money and pay off my debt and then and
you're gonna feel like you're up a creek
so you've gotta rent a house
go rent a house rent a house sell the
camper and pay off your dad
okay
and pay off your debt by Chris pay off
your debt by Christmas
okay and then then build an emergency
fund and then build a down payment and
buy another house
okay and wait
um with our pay range what what would
you suggest
um like for the amount of house we
should get you know so we've got a
calculator that's located on our site
but the parameters there is we never
want the payment your monthly payment to
be any more than 25 of your take-home
pay and that's everything all in that's
taxes Insurance HOA fees everything and
then when you go to buy the house you
want it to be on a 15-year fixed rate
conventional mortgage that's what you're
looking for
okay thank you guys so much so here's
the thing here's what it's going to feel
like truly number one
you're going to get your sanity back
this week go find a rental house
okay something something reasonable
because you're going to be there for a
year maybe a year and a half
so get something to read and then sell
the camper sell the camper what will the
camper bring
we bought it used for 20 I'm assuming we
could only get about like 17 out of it
okay so now if you take that 17 and your
other 17 you're debt free
then you're going to build up three to
six months of expenses so you're going
to be sitting on another 15 000 cash is
your next goal
okay okay but you're gonna be there
pretty quick you may be there by
Christmas
now that I don't know now that I got the
camper sold I forgot about how much it
was going to bring okay so we're dealing
with 34. you're dealing with nine
thousand dollars in your savings account
after you sell the camper and pay off
17.
okay no I'm sorry you're dealing with um
you have you're more you're gonna you're
gonna have your emergency fund
pretty close yeah no no no no no no no
34 no you're on 9 000 in there so yeah
you got to go and you got to put another
six thousand in by Christmas and here's
the thing you gotta breathe this in for
a second you're living in a nice rental
home not super pot not super expensive
because we don't want to spend too much
okay but but a whole lot better in your
situation today
okay there's a little bit of physical
room for your family to relax
and and yeah I do um
let me breathe this in I want you to
hear I want you to get this picture
the kids are calm there's a little
physical privacy in space there's
fifteen thousand dollars cash in the
bank
you don't have a payment in the world
that feels pretty darn good
yes yes for sure now we shave up a big
down payment we buy a house in the next
two years and you're doing that from a
position of strength not desperation and
frantic
zipper yeah that's exactly where I am
right now I would be too
oh
so does that make sense how much for
that yes no it's called Financial Peace
if you work this system that's what you
get that's right got to be committed to
it that's how it works there's a process
here so Jade was exactly right you got
to lay a process in there step-by-step
game plan to attack this renting is not
a sin folks
it's patience while you get your crap
together that's right and that's what we
laid out here my husband and I we rented
for 10 years well we paid off our debt
well you paid off 465 000 in debt that's
right but we understood what was on the
the end of it which is why I say when
you go into these things understand it's
a plan it's something for the Long Haul
and you've got to understand that going
in otherwise Midway through you'll bail
on it absolutely Bev is in San Antonio
hey Bev what's up
well hi Dave thank you for taking my
call sure what's up um my question is is
uh I want to know how do I preserve my
money and have it grow because I worry
about the money lasting me for the rest
of my life
um I'm 72 I don't owe any money to
anything but my income is not great
so how much of a nest egg do you have
um what I have is uh I've I've got uh
about well I have 823 000
wow that's pretty good well I know about
it so Bev how much is your house worth
my house is worth about 400 and it's
paid for
it is have you stopped and thought about
the fact that you're a millionaire
I have that's pretty bad gum code High
income I know so if your 83 000 was
making 10 that'd be 80 000 a year what
do you got your 800 000 invested in
I have it with uh a professional person
that's that's managing it for yeah how
much income is it throwing off
well you know it you know last this is
my problem in the last
I've just been
shrink no it didn't and it's gone down
no I didn't well my money it shouldn't
have shrunk because the Market's even
year over year the last 12 months the
stock market is very very slightly up
12 months ago today
okay well my problem is that I've you
know I've got a SEP IRA I've got a Roth
and I've got a savings account what's it
invested in
um in mutual funds
um with this with a professional person
yeah I know but you're the professional
person you're the one with eight hundred
thousand dollars so I want you to go sit
down with them again and give them one
chance to be a teacher
because I don't want to hear a
professional person I want to next time
I talk to you I want to know what your
money's invested in and you can't even
tell me
no just mutual funds and you got fear
around this because you don't understand
it right yeah you need to understand
what's going on with your money and if
your investment professional can't grow
a teacher bone you need to fire them and
get one that has a teacher bone
because you are in charge of eight
hundred thousand dollars because if you
were getting 10 off that you get 80 000
a year and I bet you you could live on
that what are you drawing off of it now
Bev
I'm not drawing anything I'm living on
just my Social Security and a little
annuity I'm living on uh for a year 34
33 000 a year why is that by choice
that is because I'm afraid to take any
money out I had to take out my required
withdrawal so I just so let me ask you
how if you were going to guess based on
your family history how long does Bev
live
um I'm gonna guess well into my 90s okay
so we got 20 years
okay divide 800 by 20.
even if you don't make any money on it
yeah you're not going to go out of it
no okay I just needed to hear this from
somebody like you yeah you you need to
be drawing more off but you also need to
understand more of it because you don't
have peace around it and if you can't
get this person to get you a little base
of knowledge where you feel more
comfortable about knowing what's going
on with your stuff then you need to sit
down with someone new and Check Smart
investor pro at ramseysolutions.com they
don't work for us but they're the people
with the heart of a teacher they got a
teacher bone and they'll help you with
this that's what's missing here you got
plenty of money girl you're gonna be
okay this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
scripture of the day James 1 22 be doers
of the word and not hearers only
deceiving yourselves
Yoda
we're quoting Yoda May the fourth be
with you oh there it is okay why am I
quoting do or do not there is no try can
you do it with the voice no can you
ask me to try can you can you I don't
even know what Yoda is it's weird it's
like do or dude it's like an old
person's voice yeah yes yeah don't ask
me to try yeah okay oh I did you asked
me to try so I thought it was true
that's true it's a fair trade I
embarrassed myself though Yoda May the
fourth be with you okay it does sound
like something you would say uh it's not
like something I would say no it does
sound like it does sound like something
do or not do there is no try no you
would do it in here it's about as good
as I can get your yelling voice no or do
not
don't try yeah the Dave Ramsey rant
voice yeah there we go that's good I
like that Garrett's with us Garrett's in
Kansas City hi Garrett how are you
hi Dave I'm doing great uh thank you so
much for uh giving me the time
um my dad actually uh when I was living
in California he said hey Gary you need
to listen to this I know you drive a lot
and he sent me a Dave Ramsey uh car CD
uh set and I was like oh my God my dad's
not I'm sorry uh
my dad's nuts and yet I put that in
there and since
2007 I have been debt for me
okay uh it was a hard you know it was
like it seems I listened to your disk
I just like man this guy knows what he's
talking about you know okay and so I
have been driving
I have a course I had a BMW I've had
everything and the day that I was told
if you can't afford it you don't deserve
it you know is it a want or is it a need
in that day that I read that I realized
but it doesn't matter what kind of car
or what I want or what I need it's what
it has to happen and you open my eyes
and the reason I'm calling you is
because I have followed your steps since
like 2002 I'm debt free no credit card
debt all that bull stuff
um
but I'm looking at buying a rental
property I've never owned anything
I have actually rented my whole life are
you an over the road truck driver
no no why do you not own a house
because I never I've been a nomad I just
move I move with the times I move with
the money well you don't know you don't
own a rental house
what you don't need to own a rental
house then
well I'm actually looking to plant seeds
then buy a house to live in
not rent it like a duplex
if you want to buy duplex that's okay
but living part of it
okay so that's why I called I wanted to
ask you
in this
rental property a home a home do you
know why he's saying that
yes I would love you to tell me because
you need to be if number one you've
never owned anything so and you said
that by your own admission that you're a
nomad we would want you never owned a
home I've never owned a home I've owned
a lot of cars I've owned a lot of
motorcycles it's not the same a home is
the biggest investment you're going to
have
yeah so you need to you need to just put
down roots and get you get your house
this time it's the next stage in your
personal growth and you don't need to
spend a whole lot of money on it yeah
just get you a place to live in and then
keep earning money make sure that gets
paid off when that's paid off if you
want to buy a rental save up and pay
cash for the rental but
um no I would not tell someone to buy a
rental property before they about a
personal residence and paid it off I
would first do that because that lays
down
um a foundation
for your overall financial plan more
than rental property does and you learn
what it what homeownership looks like
you understand the repairs you
understand all of those things all the
crap it's gonna break yeah yeah that's
it what it feels like to feel the
payment when your rental doesn't pay it
Scott's with us in San Antonio hi Scott
how are you
um doing good I appreciate that sure how
can we help
so um right now I'm in kind of a
financial decision right here regarding
my car repair that I still owe uh 2500
left on my vehicle and now
um I got news that my transmission is is
shot and the repair for it is going to
be 3600 that's my only vehicle and so I
don't have the funds to pay for the
repair how much do you make a year
uh make uh 48 000. okay where's all your
money gone
uh go to rent and then just the car
payment and groceries and I'm sure
that's pretty much it you married
yes how many kids you got
none she work outside the home
uh just little small gigs in my life is
under workers comp
why she is she injured yes what's what
happened
uh it was a injury at a at a daycare as
a hurt her back and so she's getting
treatment for that so there's other
kinds of work she could do
a little bit yeah no no there's a lot
that don't involve your back
like a myriad of things
okay so when you get your income up you
guys are you guys are starving to death
and you're disorganized and this stuff
is all happening to you instead of you
happening to it I've been there it is a
desperate but feeling I can hear the
fear down under your voice
and because I was the same way man I
know exactly how you feel this is not
fun I'm sorry I'm sorry you're facing
this so here's the thing your car is a
piece of crap and I wouldn't spend 3 600
to fix it because when you get done the
whole stupid thing's not worth that
am I wrong
no no you're pretty much right yeah I
mean it's a decent vehicle but yeah so
what I would do can can you scrape up a
thousand bucks
yes real fast go get you a garage go get
you a garage sale car to get back to
work and she's got to go to work dude
go get a job
it's not it's not something with their
back I'm not saying she's lazy but she's
been through this trauma of this workers
comp thing and the the people in that
world tell her to sit on her butt and
you guys need her to make 20 000 bucks a
year because it'll change your life yeah
and if you do that then you're gonna pay
off the 2500 and by Christmas you're
going to buy a five thousand dollar car
and pay cash because you're going to be
on a really tight budget living on
nothing and no more eating out you're
broke people
am I missing something
no that that's uh that's pretty clear
cut yeah yeah so here's the thing we can
do it yeah yeah and I'm going to help
you Jade and I are going to help you
okay we're going to put you into our
non-week class Financial Peace
University it's going to cost you
nothing
except a promise that you by God go
change your life and you do everything I
tell you to do because if you'll do this
stuff dude in 15 years you're going to
be a millionaire
I promise you but it'll take 15 years
and the next year is going to be a pain
in the butt for you but you're gonna be
on top of the world compared to where
you are right now because you guys have
been living from crisis to crisis to
crisis to crisis bullcrap to bullcrap to
bullcrap since you've been an adult am I
missing something
I was the same way man I was exactly the
same way so I can I can hear it oh yeah
smell it on you hey get in my class hey
she's going to be leading a class you
want to get in her class get in my class
we start Monday
you and your wife I'm gonna pay for it
it's going to cost you nothing okay
you promise you'll do it if I give it to
you free
I'm I'm we're open we're listening let's
go let's do it hang on get you a
thousand dollar car and then we're gonna
pay off this stupid car and sell it to
the junkyard for 2 500 bucks ain't even
worth 2 500 bucks
especially the transmission out of the
dumb thing and then as soon as you get
all on top of this and we're gonna move
you up out of a thousand dollar car into
a five thousand dollar car and pay cash
and then we're gonna make sure you're
debt free and you have an emergency fund
in place and you guys are gonna be
working all the time because you need 35
or 40 000 will completely completely
change your whole life
and that's all it takes that's amazing
that's not much you can do this you
totally can do this hey hang on we'll
get you signed up for free man that puts
this hour in the Ramsey showing the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]